how to ask a question on the ugly face
forms
if you have a general question or are
looking to debug your code the forums
are the place to ask in this video we'll
teach you how to write a good question
to maximize the chances you will get an
answer
first things first to login on the
forums you need an earning face account
if you haven't created one already go to
eshape.com and click sign up
there is also a direct link below
fill your email and password then
continue the steps to pick your username
and update a profile picture
once this is done go to
disqus.orginfest.com
link below and click login
use the same login information as for
the urging face website
you can search the forms by clicking on
the magnifying glass someone may already
have asked your question in a topic
if you find you can't person your topic
as a new user it may be because of the
anti-spam filters
make sure you spend some time reading
existing topics to deactivate it
when you're sure your question hasn't
been asked yet click on the new topic
button for this example we'll use the
following code
that produces an error as we saw in the
what to do when i get an error video
the first step is to pick a category for
a new topic
since our error has to do with the
transformers library we pick this
category next choose a title that
summarizes your error well
don't be too vague or users that get the
same error you did in the future won't
be able to find your topic
once you're finished typing your topic
title make sure the question hasn't been
answering the topics this course
suggests you
click on the cross to remove that window
and you have double checked
this is an example of what not to do
when posting an error
the message is very vague so no one else
will be able to guess what went wrong
for you and it takes too many people
tagging people especially moderators
might have the opposite effect of what
you want
as you send them a notification and they
get plenty they'll probably not bother
replying to you an user you didn't tag
will probably ignore the questions since
they see tagged users
only tag a user when you are completely
certain they are the best place to
answer your question
be precise in your text and if you have
an error coming from a specific piece of
code include that code in your post
to make sure your post looks good place
your question between three backticks
like this
you can check on the right how your post
will appear once posted
if your question is about an error it's
even better to include the full
traceback
as explained in the what to do when i
get an error video expand the trace back
if you're on collab
back for the code put it between two
lines containing three backticks for
proper formatting our last advice is to
remember to be nice a pleasant thank you
will go a long way into getting others
to help you
with all of that done properly your
question should get an answer pretty
quickly
you